>> THIS IS WHAT WE'LL SEE LATER
THE FIRST SHOOTER.
SO DONATO WITHS ABOUT AS AGGRES
THE PENALTY KING AS THEY KINGS
HAVE FACED ALL YOUR. THE LONG
STRETCH PASS AND ALL OF A SUDDE
IT'S AN OUTNUMBERED ATTACK.
THE PUCK, THEY
ARE KNOWN FOR THAT WITH THE
BACKEND OF THE STICK, BUT FOUR
CLICKS THE REFEREEBUILDINGS. LO.
SPRONG PUTS MEET ONCE AGAIN
THE ULTIMATE GAME IN THE REGULA
SEASON IN LATE
HERE., FOR KALIYEV AND THE PUCK
BATTLES.
>>
DONATO, HOLDING, SHOOTING, THE
LEAST PUCK, OUT OF POSITION
WINS THE DRAW, THEY AND
DISMANTLING THE COYOTES 6-1.
EDMONTONGS COULD GET
ONE HERE LATE, IT MIGHT CHANGET.
KOPITAR JOINING.
ALAL IT WASN'T
THE KINGS  KEMPE.
TO
JORDAN EBERLE OFF THE BLOCK SHO
CARRIES IT IN ON THE BREAKAWAY
AND MAKES IT 4-1.HAPPENED.
BUT IT COMES AT A TIME WHEN YOU
JUST LOOKING AT THE STANDINGS G.
PETERSEN FINALLY ABLE TO GET A
HANDLE
THE PA>> ARVIDSSON TIES APPEAR
CORNER WITH OLEKSIAK.MORE SOUGH
ONE ENDS UP GOING AND I